>> AN AMAZING NIGHT FOR EVERYONE
WHO WORKS AT FOX NEWS MEDIA.
DURING OUR FIRST-EVER SPOTLIGHTS
AWARDS DINNER.
THE EVENT HONORING THE
INCREDIBLE WORK DONE BY
EMPLOYEES AT THE NETWORK.
SUZANNE SCOTT HIGHLIGHTING THE
ROLE EVERYONE PLAYS.
>> OUR SUCCESS AT FOX NEWS MEDIA
IS A REFLECTION OF ALL YOUR
ACHIEVEMENTS, DEDICATION,
COLLABORATION, AND HARD WORK.
WE DO HAVE THE BEST TEAM IN THE
BUSINESS.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE CELEBRATE OUR
SUCCESS.
TONIGHT WE ALSO CELEBRATE
INDIVIDUAL ACHIEVEMENTS.
THE NAME COMES FROM THE IDEA OF
SHINING A LIGHT ON COLLEAGUES
THAT DO AMAZING WORK, MAKE
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIONS.
>> "THE FIVE'S" VERY OWN
PRODUCER HONORED AS ONE OF OUR
OWN UNSUNG HEROES.
>> NINA HAS TACKLED IMMENSE
PERSONAL CHALLENGES AND NEVER
WAVERED.
SHE'S ALWAYS OPTIMISTIC,
ENCOURAGING A ROCK STAR ON FULL
OF THEM.
>> NINA IS SUCH A JOYFUL PERSON,
TAUGHT ME EVERYTHING ABOUT
INEWS, BOOKING GUESTS.
YOU ARE A RAY OF SUNSHINE FOR
ALL OF US WHO GET THE PRIVILEGE
OF WORKING WITH YOU.
I'M SO THANKFUL FOR YOU.
>> SHE'S BEEN A PART OF "THE
FIVE" SINCE THE BEGINNING, WHEN
WE STARTED 11 YEARS AGO.
IT WAS A BIG NIGHT FOR GREG AND
THE ENTIRE GUTFELD TEAM WHO TOOK
HOME THE IMPACT AWARD FOR THEIR
HIT LATE-NIGHT SHOW, EXCLAMATION
POINT.
>> A REASON TO LAUGH OR HAVE
MORE FUN HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
NEEDED.
THE 2021 SPOTLIGHT IMPACT AWARD
GOES TO "THE GUTFELD SHOW" AND
THE TEAM.
>> SUZANNE SAID WHEN THIS SHOW
STARTED WAS TO MAKE PEOPLE
LAUGH, MAKE PEOPLE FEEL GOOD.
THEY DIDN'T TELL ME WHAT NOT TO
SAY, A POLITICAL DIRECTION.
THEY NEVER COULD HAVE DONE THIS
SHOW WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF
SUZANNE SCOTT, FOX LETTING US DO
WHAT WE DO.
>> THE AWARDS RECOGNIZED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS 4 OTHER
CATEGORIES, INCLUDING COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
WE ALSO FIVE RISING STARS.
AN INCLUSION AMBASSADOR OF THE
YEAR.
AND INNOVATOR OF THE YEAR.
AND THEN IN A VERY EMOTIONAL
MOMENT FOX NEWS PAYING TRIBUTE
TO PHOTOJOURNALIST KILLED
REPORTING IN UKRAINE.
OUR LONDON BUREAU CHIEF ACCEPTED
THE AWARD ON PIERRE'S BEHALF.
IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL NIGHT, A
WONDERFUL CELEBRATION, AND THE
SPOTLIGHT AWARDS ARE SUPER FUN,
EXCITING.
JUDGE, YOU ENJOYED YOUR
EXPERIENCE THERE LAST NIGHT?
>> WHAT WAS GREAT ABOUT IT,
SUZANNE SCOTT, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COMPANY OBVIOUSLY, AND THE
ABILITY FOR SO MANY PEOPLE TO
HAVE THE CHANCE TO TALK WITH
HER, TO BE WITH HER, HER
RECOGNIZING AND TOUCHING
EVERYONE.
IT SHOWS WHAT KIND OF COMPANY
THIS IS.
GREG, WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT NEVER
BEING TOLD WHAT TO SAY, WHAT NOT
TO SAY.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT FOX IS
ABOUT.
THEY REALLY GIVE US A LOT OF
ABILITY TO SAY WHAT WE WANT.
THERE'S NO DIRECTION.
AND IT'S JUST --
>> YOUR WHOLE TEAM WAS THERE.
>> IT'S A SHAME THAT JESSE
WASN'T THERE SO I COULD RUB HIS
FACE IN IT.
IN YOUR FACE, JESSE.
I GOT ON AWARD.
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THAT I HAVE NO
EMOTION.
I LIKE TO DO GOOD WORK.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT FEEL IT WORK.
>> DID YOU GET THE AWARD OR THE
STAFF?
I JUST WANTED TO CLEAR IT UP.
>> I'M LIKE A PROUD FATHER.
MY POINTING ABOUT, THIS COMPANY
IS A RARE THING, WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY DO GOOD WORK, AND ALSO
FEEL GOOD WHILE YOU'RE DOING IT.
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE IN
PEOPLE'S JOBS.
YOU KNOW, BUT IN THIS CASE, IT'S
LIKE ANYBODY THAT IS IN THIS
SITUATION IS INCREDIBLY LUCKY.
I CONSIDER MYSELF VERY LUCKY.
>> IT WAS VERY MUCH LIKE A
FAMILY.
EVERYONE WAS CLOSE.
EVERYONE AS HAPPY TO BE THERE.
>> EVERYONE WAS MAKING FUN OF
EVERYONE, RIGHT, HAROLD?
>> THE ENTIRE NIGHT.
I WAS ALSO MOVED BY ALL THE
PEOPLE WE HONORED.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR TIRELESS
WORK TO HELP MAKE THE WORK A
SUCCESS, EVEN HIGHLIGHTING THE
RISING STARS IN A SENSE.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, GREG, I
THOUGHT YOU GAVE A GREAT SPEECH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT WAS HUMANE, FITTING AND --
>> JESSE, YOU WERE MISSED.
>> I HAD A GREAT TIME LAST
NIGHT.
IT WAS A GREAT EVENT.
I THOUGHT YOU SPOKE REALLY
ELOQUENTLY.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR NEXT YEAR WHEN
PRIMETIME STAFF GETS THE AWARD.
>> AND BRET'S PIECE ON PIERRE
WAS OUTSTANDING.
>>